kevin when you think about usdc we've
talked a lot about uh the yield
component and thinking of it almost like
an investment asset that you can drive
that yield on is there a world where if
you could convince the
partners or the customers or your kind
of business
transaction uh participants to take usdc
would you move a material part or 100 of
all of your wires and kind of legacy
banking infrastructure payments to
something like usdc where you could do
it more instantaneous cheaper faster etc
yeah of course i would but i can't do
that now i mean let me explain what the
potential from my point of view as a
user of the product
one of the greatest frustrations that
i've articulated over the last couple of
years is what i do in foreign markets on
equities i i i have a an index that
involves 50 large cap european stocks
that unfortunately or fortunately
whatever you want to say are three
different currencies in swiss francs and
euros and british pounds
one of the largest friction points for
me
in rebalancing these indices
is the fact that i have to go back and
forth through fx costs for friction of
fx trading
if regulators could get behind a digital
payment system that would allow me to
own the securities in let's say usdc at
a price that's completely transparent
and liquid
um
i could avoid that friction in
perpetuity and it would be a much more
efficient way to do business to settle
in in a universal digital currency now i
know that sounds you know euphoric but
ultimately
we need to get there and and the us
dollar today is that currency it still
is
um you know many people speculate its
future but for hundreds of years it's
been the currency that people settle on
for all kinds of commodities and
services
it's very inefficient for what i'm doing
uh in these markets to to pay these
these these fx costs which vary by the
hour
and i see no value added and so
to me
let's get moving let's let's lead the
world in this in this process and this
efficiency i hate the idea that um our
regulator would hold us back against
innovation when clearly it's needed and
on the baseline of usdc which you know
there are rules for money market funds
when you go to cash in your you know
brokerage account you get swept if you
wish into a money market account that
has rarely broken a buck
and there are rules
i see no reason we can't apply that kind
of regulatory environment to usdc and
you know have that settle that way and
of course i would put more into it
because i don't know where rates are
going to be once the regulator you know
rules on usdc they probably go down
you're not going to get six percent
anymore because there'll be a flood of
institutional demand but it's going to
be better than what i'm getting on us
cash is my assumption and in addition to
that could be far more efficient as a
payment system across a wide range of
different uses i mean the use cases here
are very broad and so
you know one way to look at it and i've
tried to convince in my own
conversations with regulators and most
of us have these ongoing dialogues in
our day-to-day business
to start thinking about usdc as software
really efficient software if you're
willing to invest in microsoft and i've
said this before in google why aren't
you investing in software that has such
promise
and that's basically what in my view
it's a personal opinion but when i
invest in circle as a business i'm
investing in software that provides
tremendous productivity and efficiency
in in a business i've been in for
decades financial services and the same
for the chain for all of the other
investments i'm making in
cryptocurrencies coins tokens and
you know blockchain itself it's it's
software to me and i think it's a
necessary investment and i hope that our
regulator our regulators see that we
should lead the world in developing
these protocols and these standards and
help us do so